hello everybody and welcome to part 8 of
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent um
in case you forgot I just crashed landed
in an elevator all super badass and came
out unscathed oh yeah
rose petals I like this I'm here oh yeah
yeah I my way mmm yeah ah here ah my
bare hand is my other hands holding
lantern oh shut up I don't care what you
say
yah-ha
what do we got here
dark oh really
dark no no no no okay all right that was
disturbing now my sanity is like not
good all right that's great
Oh everything who was that who do you
think you are me
no one's me no one's as tough as I am
yeah Lulu sunlight yeah
hah hah hah hah hah hah hah hah all
there's no door
oh there's no door give me a door give
me a damn door ah oh well thank you
thank you I don't care go away I'm
protecting myself oh oh I can't move
things around last time that happened he
came right in
right
baby's gone
yeah but took one look at me and like aw
I'm not missin with that badass yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah what's up yeah yeah
that's right
back off oh boy everything's going weird
oh boy this is not good that's not good
I generally know what good is and this
is not it oh wow okay oh hey that's some
guy here bro chilling security I'm not
even scared of the big monsters what do
you think you have against them
light in here because I've got 10
kajillion timber boxes I haven't used a
single one where was that guy me who's
down there
nobody shut up all this is is a whole
lot of nothing well that was something
oh so oh hello Tonka box Oh bucket don't
make a sound
I'll shut up Oh is he puking out there
I need to talk to you
oil why don't I move the bed all right
thank you okay
all right give it there we go okay okay
okay yeah more than okay
Becca oh [ __ ] you think you're in pain
wait till I find you oh the murder girl
you must go find Gabriel the outfit and
tell them to learn the king's men please
we don't have time to make the hole any
wider
that's really sad hurry shoes I'll cover
the hole with the bed everything will be
fine Oh aah
that's what you get for implanting me
with your memories that way I can see
what's going on wait a minute I didn't
hello monsters come get some wood huh oh
I bet I bet BAM Oh what it's a hammer
what else is needed where is she
where did she go Oh Dennis
Oh Daniel you're the murderer they're
just making things worse look this is no
place for a young girl all by herself
she could be her it worse there's no
telling what horrors are way down there
yeah it's bad it's bad up here it's
probably worse down there okay I'm just
calling this right here Daniel and
Alexander are the same person
yeah that's it come on
BAM yes yeah [ __ ] off oil yep
that's all it was for stupid alright
let's go on that huh monster no uh-uh
what's up yeah get out here wind don't
need you oh yeah well I got a hammer
damn [ __ ]
I'll probably bad idea hammering the
floor underneath your feet so that you
immediately fall good logic there
good job Daniel yeah whatever
whatevs it don't matter
right left eeny Meeny I'm going this way
you don't like it tough oh look a that
seems to be the right way oh yeah oh
yeah oh come on come on now
yeah oh look at me look at me
shut up backer I need to learn their
place it's not like they're alive anyway
broad anyone else alive behind me and
these monsters lovey lovey mana
hello huh anybody harm the blue kitchen
oops end of August 1839 huh I have
arrived at the village of old stones
night it's a haven in the midst of a
vast forest on the last stop before my
final destination castle brennenburg
Castle is late our Venus and the
outrider who has been with the coaches
it's Bremen advise Bremen wait until
morning before I venture further nah
that's a real way for a bed a dear
Muller the Energy's only in and of now
waiting for the Sun to rise I try to
sleep but as I close my eyes I see the
men who fell victim in London all your
fear and shame forces me to witness the
same scenes over and over as you should
they are dead because of me
yes they are and you killed a little
girl so I don't have any pity for you
none whatsoever we got
oh yeah I got a weapon you can finally
fight back
yeah that's right
take this mouse
noises I'm trying to hide ha ha
real smart Daniel see it didn't give me
any indication but you should have been
able to go
I shouldn't stick my hand in this acid
well I mean um cool man hey piggy don't
use acid no you piggy you ready for some
acid no I don't want to take a boy I
missed but you still dissolved
anything's okay red 2 points yes one
more try
boom yeah Oh what the hell yeah
bounced off the grid was there something
in here what is the point of this room
it's anything any point
see a plane I will leave okay huh I will
stay I'll stay
Oh God aah ha ha shut up stop with the
music
Oh God Oh what is a music aah
what did I do
Oh put your legs in the acid I could
have killed it oh my god huh all right
there it's so ugly
oh god it's so ugly oh is it naked oh I
think it's naked oh ha ha ha all right
yeah oh I should've left the knife here
shanked him go get an apple uh don't get
the Apple why did he do that Daniel he
was headed away huh I'm about to punch
this monster in the face big ugly face
oh my god no one likes you anyway Oh
what is this just trying to find friends
that's too bad too ugly and too naked
Yeah right
yes yeah yeah you better run this what's
up
yeah mouse you didn't help at all you
didn't even distract him you're
squeaking miles around boom when he
comes around you don't squeak on the
other side of the room dick what am i
doing
it won't budge yet right ah no that's
fine fine I don't need your help
jerks did you wrote get here let's go
who's there oh shut up you got a cough
I got monsters chasing after me no one
cares
see wrists separate acai ah that sounds
good I'll go that way just because it's
also away from where the chains are
doesn't make a bit of difference so
brave I take the lead
uh uh I'm not go go go whoo why you go
slow huh all right okay all that bad
is he safe well it's for his own good as
shoe safe but folks now it's closed now
suck it up 18:39 read your die like I
have fled the world at all its worries
brennenburg is a majestic creation
perched upon a forest clad Hill with
towers reaching well above even the
highest pine trees are big were
following the winding road leading to
the gates
if the impression of discovering
something forgotten no journeying with
Marco Polo to the Hidden Xanadu except
with marks on where the Baron is a
peculiar but gracious man he seems well
versed in worldly matters and is not at
all as eccentric as I assumed yeah he's
my room is exquisite and I'm confident
Renault who saw her miles could even
hope to match it as the Sun sets on
brennenburg its fairytale varnish turns
to an eerie glue yeah no kidding
Alexander's strange servants and never
far away
haha is he talking about those monsters
yeah hey BIA Wow only be described as
skulking alexand or seems murder on my
presence as he puts it it seems like I
got here just in time yeah okay whatever
all right I'm gonna pause this here but
stick around part 9 will be coming up
right after this thanks for watching